in my experience
this emotional health thing
is a journey
that is rooted in Daily practice and
some days are good and some days suck
meaning some days I fail so badly
and I feel so ashamed
and I feel horrible
that I was a dick to my assistant
but one thing I learned that's so
important it's not about how many times
you screw up at this point it's making
sure you make it right through the lens
of my kids like if you you're gonna get
mad one day and you're going to yell at
your kids again and they might think
it's Daddy of old right but it's like no
no the difference is you make it right
right away it's the it's the healing
that fixes it that's the interstitial
fluid of what this stuff is about it's
making mistakes fixing mistakes as
opposed to beating yourself up and
making bigger mistakes